Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Die größten Talente des Weltfußballs. Wo spielen die eigentlich? Vor allem die außerhalb von Europa. Diese Frage haben für uns beantwortet Cavanis Friseur und mit zwei der Friseuren wollen wir jetzt auch sprechen. Hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ich begrüße sie bei mir zum einen Sascha Felter, EdSaschaFilter auf Twitter. Servus Sascha.
Hi, Grüße Max.
Schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist und ein Neuling haben wir auch noch hier in der Leitung, nämlich Amadeus Marzai, der Ed-Post ab Amadeus. Servus Amadeus.
Servus, ich freue mich sehr, hier sein zu dürfen.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr wieder hier seid. Erfahrene Hörerinnen und Hörer, denen seid ihr natürlich ein Begriff. Aber Sascha, für all diejenigen, die jetzt neu dazugekommen sind oder erstaunliche Wissenslücken haben, was zur Hölle ist Cavanis Friseur?
Wir sind ein internationaler Fußball-Blog, der sich vor allem mit internationalem Fußball beschäftigt. Mittlerweile auch stark mit dem Scouting von Talenten und Porträts von Talenten. Vor allem auch Talenten, die normalerweise nicht so im deutschen Blogger oder Medium-Tum Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Ich glaube, die Frage, warum Cavanis Friseur sowieso der Name, haben wir das letzte Mal schon geklärt. Amadeus, was habt ihr denn jetzt gemacht? Die letzte Folge war, ich glaube, ziemlich genau vor einem Jahr, da ging es um die top 110 jungen Talente des Weltfußballs. Was ist denn das, was einen jetzt aktuell auf Cavanis friseur.de erwartet?
Genau, aktuell erwartet die Leser eigentlich eine Liste von Talenten, die es jetzt vielleicht eher schwer haben bei den 110, weil 110 sind ja die besten 10 Talente auf den klassischen Elf-Positionen. Und da haben wir letztes Jahr festgestellt, dass es Spieler außerhalb von Europa sehr, sehr schwer haben. Also wir hatten auch relativ wenige Brasileerinnen und Argentinierinnen drin, dafür sehr, sehr viele Franzosen, Portugiesen. Und wir hatten dann eigentlich mal die Idee, nur einen Kleintext zu machen, wo wir vielleicht die besten Talente aus eher exotischen Ländern vorstellen, also vielleicht aus Südkorea oder anderen asiatischen Ländern, die es halt eher schwer haben, weil die 110, die 10 besten Flügelspieler oder linken Flügelspieler sind ja in der Regel dann schon Top-Talente. Und dann hat sich eigentlich so bei uns im Chat die Idee entwickelt, dass wir es eigentlich auch ein bisschen größer aufziehen. Weil jetzt so im dunklen Winter, da können wir auch ein paar Klicks gebrauchen und da dachten wir, warum dann nicht, dass wir es ein bisschen größer aufziehen.
Und ihr konntet euch doch bloß wieder nicht einigen, oder? So war es doch wahrscheinlich. Ihr habt eine Liste gemacht und dann wartet ihr auf einmal, statt 20 Spielern hattet ihr auf einmal dann 20 pro Kontinent und dann habt ihr gedacht, ach komm, dann machen wir wieder eine Serie draus.
Also 20 pro Kontinent wäre echt schön gewesen. Also wir hatten am Ende knapp 200 Spieler für die 5 Kontinente. Das hätten eigentlich auch wesentlich mehr sein können. Also so wie die Liste jetzt steht oder wie das Konzept letztendlich steht, ich weiß gar nicht, das war, glaube ich, die längste und größte Diskussion, die wir überhaupt bei Cavanis Fusser überhaupt hatten. Also wie die Spieler aufgeteilt werden. Also es ging als die Diskussion ab nach Position, ab nach Sub-Kontinenten, also weiß ich nicht, so Südostasien oder Mittelamerika. Also da waren einige hitzige WhatsApp-Diskussionen im Stand, die jeder einmal eine Diskussion auf WhatsApp geführt hat, in einem Gruppenchat. Da weiß ich, wie nervig das sein kann.
Also wie viele sind jetzt noch im Team von Cavanis Frisur im Vergleich zu wie viele angefangen haben am Anfang der Diskussion?
Es sind alle fünf, glaube ich, noch dabei, aber die Nerven waren schon durchaus mal ein bisschen lang. Also ich glaube, der Entscheidungsprozess hat ungefähr von August bis jetzt Ende Dezember, Anfang Januar gedauert, bis wir wirklich die Liste hatten. Also es zeigt, wie schwierig es durchaus auch war. Das ist alles unter einen Hut zu haben, aber ich glaube, am Ende sind wir doch alle relativ glücklich mit dem Ergebnis und der Leser hoffentlich auch.
Und wie habt ihr das dann gemacht? Also es ist ja schon bei den 110 besten Talenten auf der jeweiligen Position schwierig zu scouten. Aber wenn ihr jetzt dann eben bewusst die Talente aus Europa weglasst, dann wird es ja, stelle ich es mir noch etwas komplizierter vor. Wie kann man das denn überhaupt dann hinbekommen, da Einblicke zu kriegen in diese ja doch etwas fernere Welt des Fußballs?
Also wir haben uns halt über die letzten Talenteserie, zumindest bei der reinen Sammlung von Talenten, um eine Grundbasis zu schaffen, haben wir uns an die Listen vom Guardian gehalten. Und dann eben bei der Spezifizierung und Klassifizierung der Talente haben wir uns dann vor allem Expertenmeinungen eingeholt. Also sprich, wir haben uns zum Beispiel für Südamerika, wir haben mit Andrea Gaipp viel und her gesprochen, der Südamerika-Experte ist, vor allem auch gerade für Argentinien. Den haben wir befragt, dann für die asiatischen Länder haben wir Experten von transfermark.de gefragt. Wir haben für Australien, Ozeanien, haben wir mit Eric Hielscher gesprochen, der für Transfermark der Datenscout ist und die ganzen Datenbanken bei Transfermark pflegt. Wir hatten dieses Mal ein relativ großes Expertentum, über Spieler, die man kennt aus Südamerika oder aus Afrika, da kann man sicherlich noch etwas zu sagen, aber Spieler, die noch im Teenagelalter sind, 17 oder 16 Jahre, das ist relativ schwierig, gerade wenn sie noch in Afrika spielen. Es ist relativ schwierig, da jetzt einfach nur auf irgendwelche vermeintliche Expertenmeinungen von irgendeiner Seite darauf zu vertrauen. Da haben wir uns halt wirklich versucht, Leute ins Boot zu holen, die wirklich Ahnung davon haben.
Also was diesmal dann auch ein bisschen weniger auf eigenem Videostudium basierend, so hatte ich es ja noch beim letzten Mal verstanden, dass ihr da über Yscout und über andere Portale, die es da so gibt, viele Clips euch selber noch angucken konnt, und das geht jetzt dann logischerweise bei so einem Projekt ein bisschen schlechter.
Naja, es geht halt vor allem darum, dass wir überhaupt erstmal die Spieler aussieben mussten. Also logischerweise haben wir uns ja bei den Spielern selbst, also als dann die Listen grob fest standen, so die pro Continent fest standen, haben wir uns dann natürlich dann Spieler angeschaut und geguckt, ok, wer von denen würde da reinpassen, wer nicht, und dann, aber halt vorher mussten wir uns erstmal eine Basis schaffen und herumschauen, wer die überhaupt in Frage kommen würde. Also ich glaube, die allerwenigsten, die so den normalen Fußball verfolgen könnten, überhaupt 10 Spieler von den Fiji-Inseln oder so nennen. Also haben wir uns halt gerade so für die Typisierung und auch für die Sammlung an Spielern erstmal eine Meinung von Experten eingeholt.
Ok, super, dann lasst uns doch mal die einzelnen Kontinent durchgehen. Zu allen Spielern findet man alle Texte dann auf cavanisfriseur.de. Da veröffentlicht ihr je nach Kontinent die einzelnen Listen. Wir wollen jetzt nicht alle einzelnen Spieler durchgehen, das ist ja klar, sondern ich würde einfach vorschlagen, ihr pickt so eure Favoriten raus. So hat es ja damals bei den 110er-Listen auch sehr gut geklappt und die Hörerinnen und Hörer können dann die sonstigen Picks sich alle auf cavanisfriseur.de angucken. Amadeus, fang du doch mal an und lass uns einfach mit Afrika starten, auch weil ich weiß, dass wir zwei diesen Tab gerade offen haben. Ja, ich habe einen exklusiven Einblick in alle Listen bekommen. Wer ist denn da? Ein Spieler, wo du sagst, oder mehrere Spieler, auf die sollten wir auf jeden Fall mal ein Auge werfen.
Also ich würde gerade in Afrika zwei Spieler nennen. Einmal Musa Yuvarer. Ich hoffe, ich habe den Namen richtig ausgesprochen. Der ist rechter Flügelspieler, spielt bei Bologna und hat eigentlich eine sehr bewegte Geschichte hinter sich. Er ist eben genau wie Bakari Jatta vom HSV, der ja auch aus Gambia kommt, ist eben auch als Flüchtling oder Geflüchteter nach Europa gekommen. In dem Fall nach Italien, nicht nach Deutschland. Und hat da eben dann das Interesse von Jugend-Trainern geweckt und ist dann relativ schnell aufgestiegen und spielt jetzt eben bei Bologna. Zwar noch nicht bei den Profis, aber in der zweiten Mannschaft und hat da auch schon sehr, sehr ordentliche Zahlen aufgelegt und der wurde mir eben von unserem geschätzten Kollegen Till Oppermann sehr empfohlen. Und zum anderen würde ich dann auch Lassina Traoré nennen. Der ist Bildschwimmer von Ajax Amsterdam, hat eben auch einen sehr interessanten Weg. Er ist eben aus Burkina Faso zu Ajax Cape Town, der Ajax Filiale sozusagen in Kapstadt und von da eben jetzt nach Amsterdam und hat eben auch schon für die zweite von Ajax sehr, sehr gute Zahlen aufgelegt, hat mit, ich glaube, 19 Jahren schon 3,5 Millionen Euro Marktwert und gilt schon als Hoffnung für den Profikader und eben auch ein sehr großer bulliger Stürmer. Da gab es ja auch mal einen anderen Lassina Trauré. Dieser Lassina Trauré könnte jetzt glaube ich sogar noch bekannter werden. Also das sind zwei Namen.
Den anderen habe ich gerade vor mich und habe mich gewundert. Der ist nämlich schon 9 und 2.
Ja, auch der ist ein sehr bulliger Stürmer.
Über 2 Meter groß und hat aber halt schon 10, 11, 12 Vereine hinter sich. Also da muss man da muss man nochmal genauer ins Guggen reingehen, als ich das gerade eben mehr gemacht habe.
Also wir haben auch drei Traurigste in der Liste. Da kann es ein bisschen verwirrend werden, aber wir geben unser Bestes, dass es Klarheit gibt.
Ja, dann lass doch mal kurz bei den beiden noch ein bisschen bleiben. Also Musa Jovara eben bei Bologna. Das hat natürlich auch nochmal eine besondere Note, so eine Bakary-Jatta- Geschichte dann in Italien zu haben. Da ist die Stimmung um Flüchtlinge vielleicht noch ein bisschen zugespitzter als in Deutschland, wo sie schon zugespitzter ist, als sie eigentlich sein sollte. Der hat, wenn ich mir einfach jetzt nur das angucke, was ich da an Zahlen sehe, in 15 Spielen 14 Torbeteiligung, 9 Tore, 5 Assists. Ich glaube, das ist das, was du meinst, wenn du sagst, der hat schon ganz gute Zahlen produziert.
Ja absolut, da stimme ich dir zu. Also er wurde mir auch von Thierse Dribbel stark und schnell beschrieben. War ja schon sehr beachtlich der Weg, also gerade den er auch mit Jatta gemeinsam hat, oder schon 9 Tore und 5 Vorlagen da aufzulegen. Also gerade bei Juwara scheint es weniger der Fall zu sein. Also es könnte eine sehr spannende Entwicklung sein und natürlich auch eine wirklich einzigartige Story, aber schon eine sehr ungewöhnliche und es ist wirklich beachtlich die Zahlen. Also das ist echt ein Spieler, auf den man seinen Augenmerk halten sollte.
Ja, links außen ist ja auch eine durchaus gefragte Position und die andere gefragte Position von Lassina Traoré, eben dem 19-jährigen Lassina Traoré mit Doppel-S, so kann man ihn, glaube ich, finden. Der hat auch super Zahlen, Sascha, wenn ich mir das angucke. In 17 Spielen, dann eben bei der zweiten von Ajax hat er 13 Tore, 7 Assists, also 20 Torbeteiligung in 17 Spielen. Das hört sich tatsächlich auch sehr gut an.
Ja, also generell muss man ja sagen, dass es gerade junge Spieler oder gerade vor allem junge Offensivspieler in Holland ziemlich, ich will nicht sagen leicht haben, aber die Chancen, sich dort gut zu entwickeln, ist relativ hoch, weil fast alle Mannschaften in Holland ziemlich offensiv spielen. Das ist natürlich dann gerade bei einem Verein wie Ajax, der sowieso dafür bekannt ist, großartige Offensivspieler hervorzubringen. Sein Cousin Bertrand Trauré hat ja auch bei Ajax gespielt, bis vor drei Jahren glaube ich, ist dann zu Lyon gewechselt. Da ist es wahrscheinlich dann auch ein Anreiz gewesen, dann den Schritt nach in die Niederlande zu gehen und dann eben auch einfach den nächsten Schritt zu gehen und dort durchzustarten. Aber an sich ist auch er wirklich ein super Spieler, Triple-Starke, wirkt ziemlich bullig, ist aber relativ wendig und auch sehr schnell. Also den könnte man auch erwarten, dass er in den nächsten zwei bis drei Jahren den nächsten Schritt geht. Also ohne jetzt sagen zu wollen, er wird jetzt bis zu Realwechsel nur zu Wasser, weil das wäre sicherlich zu viel.
Aber vielleicht sind die Talente ja sogar noch interessanter. Das habe ich mir nämlich bei der letzten Liste gedacht und auch als ich die, ihr hattet ja schon mal so eine Liste gemacht, als ich die nochmal durchgegangen bin, da dachte ich mir wie schade, dass eigentlich erst für ganz viele Leute, die das hier hören, dass man von tollen Talenten hört, aber die landen halt, wenn alles dann tatsächlich so halbwegs kommt, wie man das an ihrem Talent beobachten kann in jungen Jahren, landen die halt bei 10, 15 Top-Clubs und dann gibt es vielleicht noch eine Riege von 10 drunter. Da sind die jetzt tatsächlich vielleicht noch ein bisschen interessanter, weil die halt vielleicht auch, also die werden halt nicht alle bei Real Madrid landen. Real Madrid ist dicht. Das ist sehr schwierig, da reinzukommen. Aber halt bei vielleicht dem FC Valencia oder eben halt beim FC Valencia Deutschland Schalke 04. Oder, na, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ja, aber das finde ich, das ist doch gerade das Schöne daran. Also generell kann ich irgendwie Listen nicht trauen oder irgendwie ein Artikel oder irgendetwas veröffentlicht, wo steht ja hier die 100 besten oder die 50 besten Talente, wo drin nicht 40 von denen dann im Sommer bei Barca spielen werden oder bei Men's City spielen werden. Da wäre ich generell erst mal schon misstrauig. Also es muss halt nicht irgendwie jedes Talent irgendwie bei den ganz großen Vereinen spielen. Das ist auch okay, wenn die bei Darmstadt oder bei Mainz oder so spielen oder bei Swansea City. Also es ist auch völlig okay. Und wenn jetzt aus dieser Liste von den 50 Schülern, wenn da eine Handvoll bei wirklich großen Spitzenvereinen landet, dann ist das wirklich schön. Sehr, sehr gut. Weil es kann wirklich damals so viel passieren. Also bestens Bayerisches, da finde ich immer noch Emre Mohr, als er 2016 zu Dortmund gewechselt ist, dachten ja alle, ui, wunderschön, was da geschehen wird. Und dann wird halt irgendwie schlecht beraten oder verletzt sich oder wie auch immer. Und schon spielt er halt überhaupt keine Rolle mehr. Also da spielen halt viel zu viele Sachen mit rein, die wir überhaupt gar nicht vorher sehen können oder beeinflussen können. Das können ja nicht mal die Vereine, die den Spieler letztendlich verpflichten. Also da meiste ich mir auch nicht an, dass wir da als kleiner Block, der das irgendwie hobbymäßig macht, da irgendwie die absolute Weisheit oder die absolute Recht darauf hat, dass wir das Recht haben, den Spieler richtig einzuschätzen.
Ja gut, aber ihr habt halt viel Mühe und viele Expertenmeinungen drauf gesetzt, diese Auswahl zu treffen. Deswegen, also man kann da glaube ich sehr gut schon mal so vor Abwissen einsammeln und dann später mal glänzen in der Fußballrunde. Wenn man sagt, ah ja klar, der kam ja damals nach Bologna und der hat ja damals schon in der zweiten sehr, sehr gut gespielt. Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob der sich jetzt durchsetzt bei Darmstadt.
Ja genau, das habe ich mir auch überlegt. Also das versuchen wir auch, den Mehrwert zu schaffen. Also wenn dann mal später, dann weiß ich nicht, Ibrahim Said aus Nigeria, vielleicht nicht bei Real Madrid landet, sondern bei Mönchengladbach, dann kann vielleicht einer der Leser, einer unserer Leser, der Gladbach-Fan ist, in der Vereinskneipe auf dem Tisch schauen und sagen, da habe ich mal vor zwei Jahren einen Top-Artikel gelesen. Und dieses Wissen wollen wir geben. Und das ist ja gerade auch das Schöne im internationalen Fußball. Also die Talente, die wir aufgelistet haben, sind ja, wie Sascha schon angedeutet haben, in einem sehr sensiblen Alter. Da kann ein Wechsel oder eine kleine Verletzung oder ein kleines Formtief schon, sag ich mal, den Karriereknick bedeuten. Aber es ist eben dann auch sehr interessant, oft im Nachhinein zu beobachten, dass, wenn ein Spieler eben auch, wie du schon angedeutet hast, mag es andere Karrierewege gehen, die dann zwar vielleicht nicht ganz die erste Riege sind, aber bei Valencia zu landen, aus Südkorea wie Kangin Lee zum Beispiel, ist ja auch schon eine absolut tolle Sache.
Und das könnt ihr noch kurz sagen, das haben wir glaube ich in dieser Folge noch gar nicht angesprochen. Was ist denn die Altersgrenze Amadeus bei den Spielern?
Der Stichtag war, was? Sascha, hilf mir mal aus. 1999 oder Ende 1999?
Nee, 2000. Also erst der erste. 2000. Wer sich an dieser Stelle noch nicht alt fühlt, ich weiß nicht, jetzt sollte man sich alt fühlen, wenn es 2000 ist. Also ich bin auch noch gar nicht so alt, aber als ich gelesen habe, so 2000, Stichtag, so pfff.
Also gut, also es sind quasi die bis maximal 20 Jahre, aber nur wenn man früh im Jahr Geburtstag hat, um so zu formulieren jetzt für heute. Okay Sascha, dann lass mal weitermachen bei den Talenten. Gibt es denn noch welche aus Afrika, auf die du noch gerne hinweisen wollen würdest?
Also mein absoluter Lieblingsspieler, über den ich auch geschrieben habe, ist Cito Luwumbu. Also sein kompletter Name ist Cito Andres Sebastiao Luwumbu. Angolaner. Auch ein Flügelspieler, wahnsinnig trippelstark, ist wirklich ein Superspiel. Hat auch schon zwei Wochen bei Manchester United Probo-Training gemacht, ist dann erstaunlicherweise ins zurück nach Angola gewechselt, also zu seinem aktuellen Team. Spielt mittlerweile auch schon mit gerade mal 19 Jahren der Champions League, ist wirklich Stammspieler dort. Also bei ihm dauert es wirklich nicht mehr lange, bis er dann nach Europa weg oder zu einem größeren Verein wechselt in Europa. Also bei ihm kann ich es mir wirklich vorstellen, das wäre vielleicht einer dieser vorhin angesprochenen 5 Spieler, die den Sprung vielleicht mal zu einem etwas größeren Verein schaffen.
Cito André, Sebastia Oluwumbo. Ach, allein die Namen lohnen doch eure Liste schon. Dann lasst mal weiter hüpfen nach Asien. Sascha, wenn du jetzt eh schon gerade im Reden bist, wer aus dem asiatischen Fußballraum, wen findest du denn da besonders vorzuheben?
Ja, also da gibt es natürlich zwei, die halt absolut herausragen. Das sind einmal Takefusa Kubo, der ja im Sommer zur Real gewechselt ist, aktuell in Mallorca ausgeliehen ist. Und Kangin Lee, der bei Valencia spielt, kommt aus Südkorea. Ja gut, das sind natürlich die beiden, die alles in Asien überstrahlen in dieser Serie. Also sind mehr oder weniger Stammspieler oder spielen eine gute Rolle in La Liga-Clubs, in denen man sicherlich auch einiges in der Zukunft erwarten kann. Aber mein Favorit war tatsächlich Ketio Nakamura von Twente, Enskille. Auch ein Japaner hat eigentlich eine relativ gute Quote, also hat auch schon vier Tore geschossen, ein Tor vorgelegt, relativ wenig Spielzeit. Das wäre halt so ein angesprochener Spieler, der vielleicht nicht dieses absolute Top-Level erreicht, aber für einen ambitionierten Europa League-Club durchaus mehr was bieten könnte.
Also auch Flügelspieler, 19 Jahre alt, und eben die noch nicht so viele Minuten gemacht in der Eredivise, aber in den Minuten hat er schon ein bisschen was produziert. An 14 Partien war er mit beteiligt, aber nicht über 90 Minuten besonders viel, aber da schon 4 Tore, eine Vorlage. Das zeigt so in die Richtung. Erzähl mir noch ein bisschen was zu Kangin Li oder Amadeus, auch gerne du. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer von euch beiden da tiefer drin ist, der bei Valencia ist, und danach möchte ich auf jeden Fall auch noch was zu Kubo hören. Aber lasst mal mit Li bei Valencia anfangen. Was zeichnet den denn aus?
Ich glaube, dass Sascha tiefer in der Materie.
Ja, gut, also Li ist halt so ein, es klingt jetzt wirklich ein bisschen plakativ, wenn ich das sage, aber er ist halt so ein kleiner, wuseliger Südkoreaner. Wer hat das damals gesagt, glaube ich? Franz Bettenbauer oder Günter Netzer? Die kleinen wuseligen Südkoreaner. Er ist halt wirklich ein kleingewachsener zentraloffensiver Mittelfeldspieler, der einfach unfassbar Schallverteidigung zu fassen ist. Er hat halt wirklich eine ziemlich gute Positionierung zwischen den Linien, bietet sich immer gut an, macht Bälle gut, festdreht dann auf. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen wie Messi, das ist auch wieder abgedroschen, aber er ist halt gerade für die Gegenspieler extrem schwer und auch ekelig zu verteidigen, weil er immer so kurze kleine Haken schlägt. Bei Valencia ist er jetzt in den letzten Wochen, also er pendelt immer so zwischen Kurzeinsätzen und Bank, aber ihm hoffe ich mir eigentlich auch, dass er im Laufe der Rückrunde jetzt in La Liga komplett durchstattet und vielleicht auch zum Stammspieler dort reifen kann. Aber das Problem ist halt bei Valencia, dass Valencia meistens mit einer Doppelspitze agiert und deswegen kein Platz für einen echten Zehner frei ist.
Und ein paar Verletzungen hat er auch, das hat ihn noch so am Ende der Hinrunde bzw. zum Jahreswechsel dann so ein bisschen rausgeworfen, aber immerhin halt auch schon in der Champions League, bis auf das eine Spiel, in dem er verletzt war, war er in jedem auf dem Platz gestanden, da hilft ihm, dass er im allerersten Spiel eine Minute spielen durfte gegen Chelsea, aber ansonsten beim 4 zu 1 gegen Lille z.B. 54 Minuten gespielt, eben genau auf dieser offensiven Mittelfeldposition. Also da scheint schon einiges zu passen, sonst würde er nicht so viele Minuten bekommen. Und dann Takefusua Kubo, du hast schon gesagt, Real Madrid, eigentlich der Verein, zu dem er gewechselt ist, aber jetzt ausgeliehen an Mallorca. Entspricht ja auch so dem Klischee, was wir von Fußballern aus der Region haben.
Ja, wobei ich muss halt sagen, dass ich Kubo gerne bei einem anderen Team sehen würde in La Liga, also nicht bei einem Team, was im Abschiebskampf steckt und mit vielen langen Bällen agiert, sondern wirklich bei keinem bei Real Sociedad San Sebastian zum Beispiel. Wäre halt cool, bei einem wirklich Ballbesitz veranlagten Team, was Kubos stärken auch im Ballbesitzspiel sehr entgegenkommt.
Also spielt eher rechtsaußen, so wie ich sehe, ist ein Japaner. Also wir haben hier kurz quasi nicht den Kontinent, aber das Land gewechselt und hat schon deutlich mehr Einsätze jetzt gehabt bei Mallorca. Also 19 mal war er mit dabei, zehnmal davon in der Startelf. Das aber schon deutlicher etabliert, aber halt bei einem Verein, der sehr viele Niederlagen einsteckt und auch viele zu null Niederlagen.
Ja, das trifft eigentlich auf den Punkt. Ich würde gerne bei einem besseren Verein sehen, ob er vielleicht auch bei einer Ballbesitzmannschaft sein Stempel aufdrücken kann.
Wo wir gerade in Asien sind, würde ich gerne noch mal auf den wahrscheinlich besten Namen unserer Serie verweisen. Alahiyaz Hayatmanesh ist gerade erst 18 Jahre alt und schon bei Fenerbahçe Istanbul. Er dürfte vielleicht im einen oder anderen deutschen Fan noch in Erinnerung bleiben, weil er die deutsche U17 bei der U17 WM 2017 in Indien beim 4 zu 0 Sieg mit abgeschossen hat. Also er hat glaube ich einen Torn eine Vorlage gemacht.
Ich wusste doch, die ganze Zeit klingelt irgendwas bei mir. Jetzt weiß ich, die U17 WM.
Apropos Indien. Und zwar Inde haben wir auch dabei. Wahrscheinlich so mit die exotischsten Spieler. Beide sogar Torhüter. Also da warten auch noch relativ interessante Texte. Einer von den beiden, Diraj Singh, wurde sogar schon mit Gladbach und Freiburg in Verbindung gebracht. Also wer da schon vielleicht den nächsten Stammkeeper scouten will, der sollte sich vielleicht in der Namen Diraj Singh schon mal merken.
Stark. Ach, das mag ich. Und bei Torhütern, da weiß man ja auch immer, wenn Sascha da seine Finger mit im Spiel hat, da wird bei den Torhütern nochmal ganz besonders hingeguckt. Zumindest, wenn ich mich so an so manchen Tweet von dir erinnere.
Die Torhüter-Analyse.
Wir kommen doch zu den richtig interessanten Torhütern.
Okay, ich hab mich schon gewundert, dass die hier in eurem internen Doc nicht mit dir drin standen als Autor. Vielleicht der richtige Moment, um zu Nordamerika zu wechseln. Denn da sehe ich zum Beispiel einen Torhüter, bei dem du als Autor eingetragen bist. Ist es denn auch... Eduardo Garcia ist der Name. Dazu ist es denn auch einer von denjenigen, den du hervorheben würdest aus dieser Riege an Fußballern?
Tatsächlich, ja. Eduardo Garcia war ja der Torhüter, der bei der U19-WM 2009, also quasi letztes Jahr, gegen die Niederlande im Elfmeterschießen 3 Elfmeter gehalten hat.
Wer erinnert sich nicht?
Wer erinnert sich nicht? Legendäres Spiel damals in Brasilien, wahrscheinlich irgendwann 0 Uhr deutscher Zeit. Ja, im Grunde hat er ein bisschen das Pech, dass Guillermo Ochoa aktuell immer noch der Kultheld in Mexiko ist, was den Torhüterpositionen angeht. Ich glaube, dass Eduardo Garcia in den nächsten 2-3 Jahren nachrücken kann, ohne zu sagen, dass er das muss. Gerade auf Torhüterpositionen ist es immer schwierig, Prognosen zu treffen, weil sich die meisten erst zu 24, 25 Jahren weiterentwickeln und dann auch tatsächlich zum Stammkeeper werden. Diese Donnarumas sind eher die Seltenheit. Selbst in Mexiko.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, dann ist der Mann 17 Jahre alt. Ich würde dann fast nur von einem Jungen sprechen und spielt in der U17 von Deportivo Galahara. Ist das der richtige Eduardo Garcia, den ich da gefunden habe?
Das ist der korrekte Eduardo Garcia. Tatsächlich gab es auch in unserer allerersten Talente-Serie, also ja, von 2017, hatten wir auch einen Kiefer drin, Raúl Gaudinho, der ebenfalls von Guadalajara kam, dann zu Porto gewechselt ist. Und seitdem jetzt wieder zurück in dieser mexikanischen Stadt mit G spielt. Ich hatte bei der Recherche so ein bisschen Angst, dass Garcia eventuell ein ähnliches Schicksale eilen könnte, wenn er zu früh wechselt. Dass er dann quasi im Ausland nicht sein Glück findet, dann wieder zurückwechselt nach Mexiko und dort im Endeffekt ähnlich wie Codino oder Codinho dann auf der Bank sitzt, weil das macht er ja aktuell. Das ist halt glaube ich das Problem für Garcia, jetzt in die erste Männermannschaft aufzusteigen, weil es da aktuell einfach keinen Platz für ihn geben würde. Aber er ist wie gesagt immer noch 17 Jahre, also er verlangt den Schiff von einem 17-jährigen da jetzt schon Stammspieler zu sein.
Aber wie kommt man auf so einen Spieler? Hast du das Spiel damals gesehen, das Elfmeterschießen? Hast du dir gedacht, den merke ich mir, in zwei Jahren schreibe ich über den Text?
Na gut, das Spiel gegen die Niederlande, das war in diesem Jahr.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich es verwechselt mit dem...
Nee, alles gut. Klar merkt man sich dann halt, Performances bei diesen Jugend-Turnieren, diesen war natürlich auch für uns eine relativ große Informationsgrundlage, wie eben Spiele bei verschiedenen Ternieren abgeschnitten haben.
Ja, wie es ja bei Scouts tatsächlich auch der Fall ist. Also da muss man sich ja auch nicht für schämen. Diese U-Turniere sind in diesem Alter, also wenn wir einfach von so jungen Spielern sprechen und von nicht Europäern, besonders wichtig. Amadeus, wen aus Nordamerika wirst du mir noch unbedingt vorstellen, den ich dann ganz, ganz hektisch nachgoogle, während du sprichst?
Aus Nordamerika habe ich mich leider nicht so intensiv mit beschäftigt. Deswegen, da bin ich leider als Einziges von den Ländern komplett oder als Einziges von den Kontinenten komplett raus. Aber dafür haben wir uns immerhin namhafte Experten wie Zach Lowry an Bord geholt, der Efrain Alvarez, der Efrain Alvarez gemacht hat, der ja auch als eines der nächsten anstehenden mexikanischen Top-Talente gilt, spielt bei Los Angeles Galaxy. Und ja, da darf der Leser, genau wie ich, sehr gespannt sein mit dem Text.
Das habe ich schon gesehen, über Josh Sargent wird er schreiben. Und wir haben auch einen anderen bekannten Namen, Giovanni Reina, jetzt gerade besonders bekannt. Den kannten vorher schon BVB-Fans. Aber ich würde sagen, seit der Rückrunde kennen ihn auch andere Bundesliga-Fans. Hatte jetzt auch im DFB-Pokal ein wunderbares Tor gegen Werder Bremen geschossen.
Er war gestern auf Platz 1 bei dem Transfermarkt.
Tja, siehst du an, da hättet er mal eure Nord-Amerika-Talente schon vorher.
Die Leiden der Blogger.
Ja, nicht immer alles nur nach den Klicks sehen, das ist schon gut. Es steht jetzt da und wer immer diese Leute googelt, der wird ja immer auch bei euch landen. Das ist ganz sicher, egal wie lange sie noch bei Gadda La Hara spielen oder wo auch immer. Je länger, desto besser eigentlich für euch. Dann findet man vor allem bei euch Informationsquellen dazu. Dann lass doch, wenn Nordamerika auch so wirklich mit namhaften Experten ja auch gespickt ist, die da Artikel geschrieben haben, dann lass doch weiter wechseln zu Australien, Ozeanien. Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Amadeus, ich weiß nicht, wie sehr du da involviert warst. Gibt es da jemanden, der dir am Herzen liegt?
Also mir liegt am ersten Raphael Leay von den Salomonen Islands oder den Salomonen Insel am Herzen. Der ist eben Stürmer und hatte schon immerhin den Sprung nach Neuseeland geschafft mit 17 Jahren. Was bisher eher ungewöhnlich war, dass eben Spieler aus Ozeanien nach Neuseeland gehen, aber es ist natürlich die erste größere Liga. Hat auch schon für die Salomonen in der U17 in acht Spielen acht Tore geschossen und war bei der U17 WM auch einer der besten Spieler. Seines Landes stand natürlich auch auf verlorenen Posten. Klar, aber gilt eben für Ozeanien, jetzt abseits von Neuseeland, als eben das größte Offensivtalent und ist Mittelstürmer. Und das wäre so ein Spieler, wenn der es irgendwie mal nach Europa schafft, wenn auch nur in eine zweite Liga oder so. Das fände ich schon ziemlich nice.
Ja, also allein die Schreibweise ist natürlich wunderbar, mit Raphael noch ganz normal und dann L, E, Apostroph, Ai. Aber da wird es halt auch wirklich schwierig, die Zahlen zu interpretieren. Ich hab mir mal seine acht U17-Spiele angeguckt. Und das ist halt, da spielt man, okay, gegen Neuseeland, 5 zu 0 gewonnen, okay, bemerkenswert, dann gegen Vanuatu, also die U17-Mannschaften natürlich jeweils, gegen die Fitchi und gegen, ja, das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen peinlich, dass ich gerade nicht weiß, ach, Papua New Guinea ist PNG U17. Papua New Guinea, also was ich dazu nur sagen will, ist klar, acht Tore in acht Spielen. Aber dann bei der U17-Weltmeisterschaft 05 gegen Italien, 07 gegen Paraguay, 0 zu 8 gegen Mexiko. Total schwierig zu sagen, was das dann tatsächlich wert ist, finde ich.
Aber ich glaube, gerade da ist es auch schwierig eben, wenn die Vorleuter, oder die Vorderleute halt, da hängst du dann als Mittelstürmer natürlich in der Luft.
Jaja, klar.
Aber ja, gerade da gerade eben, was man gelesen hat, als einer der besseren. Und wir haben jetzt, oder zumindest bei Transfermarkt, eh noch keine Zahlen aus Neuseeland. Aber ja, da dürfen wir eben sehr gespannt sein, ob er eben seine überragende Quote auch, zumindest ansatzweise, in Neuseeland halten darf. Aber genau das macht ja gerade unsere neue Serie aus, dass eben auch solche Namen dabei sind, die jetzt eben bei den 110 keine Chance hätten. Und wo es sich wirklich, glaube ich, lohnen kann, die Entwicklung mit zu verfolgen. Also immerhin einer von zwei Spielern aus den Salomonen. Der andere hat einen schönen Namen, Leon Cufana.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn, was ist denn da auf den Salomonen los?
Powerhouse, aber ich glaube, die Salomonen waren sowieso immer schon eine der immerhin nicht ganz so Nationen am Tabellenende der FIFA-Rankings. Aber ja, schon interessant. Also wir haben Tahiti, Fiji, die Salomonen. Also nicht nur Australien und Neuseeländer, keine Sorge.
Ja, sehr cool. Ist auch der Kapitän der U17. Als Innenverteidiger tun ihm natürlich die von mir vorhin zitierten WM-Ergebnisse ein bisschen weh. Also das ist ja dann eine Torbilanz von 0 zu 20 am Ende gewesen. Aber ist auch ein bold move von euch. Ah, ist du mir leid, das wird blöd. Angizismus ist auch dann eine mutige Entscheidung von euch, den Innenverteidiger, der 0 zu 20 als Bilanz bei der WM hatte, trotzdem auf die Liste zu packen. Und das meine ich jetzt ganz ernst, ich finde das super. Weil man darf ja auch nicht immer nur nach diesen Ergebnissen gehen, aber dass die Solomon-Insen gegen Italiens U17 keinen Stich machen, ist jetzt auch nicht so wirklich völlig verwunderlich.
Also man muss schon sagen, wir haben natürlich auch Absicht gemacht, wenn wir jetzt nur danach gegangen wären, wenn die 10 besten Spieler Australiens und Ozeaniens wären, dann wären höchstwahrscheinlich nur Australien und Ozeania drin. Aber gerade eben Cofana und Leay, wenn ich es richtig ausgesprochen habe, haben schon relativ viel Beachtung und Lob bekommen. Und da sind wir auch eingestiegen, haben uns natürlich bei Insta auch video-technisch schlau gemacht. Und von daher, ich glaube, wir als Blog haben da nichts zu verlieren und der Leser auch nicht.
Sehr gut. Und allein die Namen. Ich muss jetzt mal hier, glaube ich, ein paar Namen vorlesen. Ich habe es bisher zurückgehalten, aber jetzt muss es raus. Wir haben aus Tahiti ein Torwart, Moanu Pitu. Dann haben wir aus Neuseeland ein Verteidiger, Liberato Kakase. Dann haben wir zwei Australier, Jacob Italiano und Noah Botich. Raphael Leay hat mir dann schon natürlich Max Maiter aus Neuseeland. Natürlich sensationeller Vorname vor allem. Ein Verteidiger aus Tahiti, Tevaitini Toimere. Nee, der wird auf gar keinen Fall Toimere ausgesprochen. Ja, also das war völlig falsch ausgesprochen. Kishan Sami von den Fiji-Inseln, wahrscheinlich auch eher Sammy. Und dann Sam Sutton von Neuseeland. Ein Mittelfeldspieler, der allein wegen des Namens bitte näher an den europäischen Fußballrücken soll. Ich finde, Sam Sutton ist ein schöner Name. Sascha, bei welchem... Da hat er einen Satenschuss. Sascha, bei welchem dieser Namen hast du gezuckt und hast gesagt, da will ich noch was erzählen.
Also einmal Liberato Cacace. Karkasse. Ja, wahrscheinlich Karkasse. Es ist halt halb Italiener, halb Neuseeländer. Ist eigentlich der beste Links-Duteiliger der australischen Liga, spielt bei Wellington Phoenix. Also der Typ ist wirklich eine absolute Rakete. Ihm wird es auch nicht wundern, wenn er in den nächsten ein bis zwei Jahren in Europa irgendwo spielt. Ganz nicht dynamischer Links-Duteiliger, kreativen Ball. Ihm traue ich wirklich den Sprung nach Europa zu. In absehbarer Zeit. Und natürlich auch Moana Pito, der Torhüter aus Tahiti. Weil du vorhin angesprochen hast, dass wir die Coronas hatten, da einen Inverteidiger reinzunehmen, der relativ viele Gegentreffer bekommen hat in drei Spielen. Moana Pito hat auch in drei Spielen 15 Gegentreffer. Der U17 WM hat sogar leichtes Übergewicht als Torhüter.
Die Katze ist ja nicht so schlecht für Torhüter, wenn Naschkatze spielt.
Ja, das stimmt. Naschkatze. Ja, bei ihm sieht man, dass er ab und zu gerne mal eine Bulette mehr am Profil zu sich nimmt. Was an sich spannend war, gerade bei den Ländern aus Australien, Ozeanen und eher exotischen Ländern, zu beobachten, wie die Ausbildung verschiedener Spieler war. Gerade bei Torhütern war das für mich extrem interessant zu sehen, weil nach europäischen Maßstäben das immer so gehandhabt hat, dass jeder ordentlich zu hechten hat, jeder eine ordentliche Körperspannung haben soll usw. Bei Pito kam es mir zuvor, als hätte er immer am Strand trainiert. Dem Ball wurden die Bälle am Strand zugeworfen. Er hat sich möglichst spektakulär danach gehechtet. So ist auch sein Torhüter. Er ist nicht der absolut sauberste Torhüter, was Stellungsspiel oder was Abdruckverhalten angeht. Aber er macht, finde ich, ziemlich wenig, macht einfach ziemlich viel. Wenn ein Schuss auf einen Mann halbhoch kommt, dann hechtet er sich und lenkt ihn da drüber und rollt sich noch dreimal ab. Er sieht cool aus, weil er einige Super-Saves auch machen kann, wo du denkst, Respekt, was er noch gehalten hat. Er hat jetzt auch die Chance, bei seinem Verein in Tahiti, da in der Champions League zu spielen. Was ich einfach cool finde, als 20-jähriger, 19-jähriger.
Der AS Tefana ist, wenn ihr euch das gefragt habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da kann man dann die Naschkatze ihre Wirbel machen lassen. Wobei, ich sollte vielleicht nicht so über ihn sprechen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie er aussieht und wie er spielt. Ein bisschen respektlos. Dann lasst uns nach Südamerika gehen. Ich vermute mal, dass da dann die Auswahl ein bisschen schwieriger war. Und dass euch der liebe Andreas, den natürlich alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer auch schon kennen, aus unseren zwei Folgen zum Finale der Copa Lepradoris, im vorletzten Jahr war das, glaube ich. Der ist allen schon bekannt und der wird euch da geholfen haben. Auf wen habt ihr euch dann einigen müssen? Und wer sticht da noch heraus, Amadeus, wenn du dir jetzt diese Liste noch mal anschaust?
Also mein Lieblingsspieler aus der gesamten Liste, der jetzt eben auch aus Südamerika kommt, ist Brian Rodriguez, auch ein toller Name, wie ich finde. Bei dem ich wirklich kämpfen musste gegen meine geschätzten Kollegen, dass er es auch in die Liste schafft, spielt eben noch beim Los Angeles FC, der noch relativ neu gegründet ist. Hat bisher auch noch relativ wenig Profi-Spiele gemacht. Aber in den Spielen, die er gemacht hat, hat er schon wirklich unfassbares Talent angedeutet, hat auch schon sechs Länderspiele gemacht, in denen drei Tore geschossen. Dazu sei gesagt, dass der Trainer von Uruguay, also Oscar Tabares, sich eigentlich immer schwer tut, gerade junge Offensivspieler in die 1. Mannschaft zu integrieren. Aber er hat gerade gegen Costa Rica und Ungarn wirklich tolle Tore gemacht, ist wirklich sehr, sehr schnell, technisch sehr, sehr versiert und verliert eben auch mit dem Ball am Fuß kaum Tempo. Und man kann ihn ja mal googeln, also Brian Rodriguez wie Brian geschrieben. Wirklich einen tollen Flair mit dem Ball am Fuß. Und Napoli war sogar schon oder soll bereit gewesen sein, im Winter 30 Millionen Euro hinzulegen, obwohl er eben bisher in Amerika jetzt statistisch gesehen noch nicht so viel gezeigt hat. Aber seine Ansätze sind anscheinend wirklich schon so gut, dass selbst Klubs in Napoli sagen, da nehmen wir richtig viel Geld in die Hand.
Und da sagt dann Los Angeles FC, no, den wollen wir hier behalten.
Gute Frage, wie das zusammenhängt. Aber ich glaube, es würde ihm auch wirklich besser tun, noch mal ein Jahr mindestens in Amerika zu verbringen, weil das erste Jahr in den USA ist noch nicht so überragend. Seinen besten Profifußball hat er bisher wirklich in der Nationalmannschaft gezeigt. Aber da geht er jetzt auch bald, oder ich glaube, jetzt die Tage, sogar die Saison, oder gingen die schon los, ich glaube, die gingen sogar schon los in den USA. Also da darf man sehr, sehr gespannt sein. Nicht umsonst ist der Spitznamen El Raito der Blitz.
Das hört sich tatsächlich vielversprechend an. Die Saison wird starten am 29. Februar. Die aktuelle MLS-Saison. Da sind wir dann doch noch in der... Ich wollte gerade sagen Winterpause, aber ist natürlich Quatsch. Also die Saison geht bald los. So ist es richtig. Sascha, wen gibt es noch auf der Liste, den wir uns unbedingt merken sollten? Ich merke schon, das ist jetzt ein bisschen was anderes, als über tahitianische Torhüter zu sprechen.
Naja, dann würde ich einfach mal... Schöner Literatio. Ich wollte ja mal sagen, das sprechen wir einfach mal über kolumbianische Torhüter. Ja, Kevin Mier, Meyer, keine Ahnung, wie er ausgesprochen wird. Torhüter Kolumbiens, der auch als bester Torhüter der U17 Südamerika-Meisterschaft vor zwei Jahren ausgezeichnet wurde, ist an sich schon vom Torhüterspiel ziemlich weit. Gerade was die ganze Strafraumbeherrschung angeht, ist er überdurchschnittlich gut, würde ich sagen. Er traut sich wirklich, bei den Flanken rauszugehen. Er fängt die Flanken auch mit ziemlicher Erfolgsstabilität runter. Was auch noch viel wichtiger ist, finde ich, dass wenn er dann die Bälle mal abgefangen hat, dann schaltet er einfach wahnsinnig schnell um. Er fängt den Ball, das machen halt viele Torhüter, gerade auch auf Bundesliganiveau, noch nicht so gut. Die fangen den Ball, dann gucken sie erstmal, dann laufen sie weiter und dann werfen sie. Er fängt den Ball, rennt einfach vor bis zur 16. Kante und meistens noch im Laufen wirft er den Ball oder schlägt den Ball dann ab. Das ist vor allem eine Stärke, die noch nicht alle haben auf dem Niveau, selbst schon ältere Torhüter. Nicht mal in Südamerika haben das. Was ich auch sagen muss, dass er gerade im 1 gegen 1 eine richtig gute Positionierung hat. Er weiß eigentlich immer, wo er gerade richtig steht. Er macht eigentlich relativ wenige Fehler, was diese reine Positionierung angeht. Fehler macht er eigentlich nur bei Fernschüssen. Da ist er manchmal etwas unsicher, weil gerade Aufsetzer kann er relativ schlecht verteidigen. Da legt er sich viel zu früh auf irgendeine Seite fest oder geht zu früh runter. Dann muss er den Ball irgendwie noch nachfassen, nochmal fangen. Das ist seine einzige Schwäche, die er bisher hat.
Er hat vor allem in der Nationalmannschaft echt beeindruckende Werte. In neun Spielen bei der U20-Süd-Amerika-Meisterschaft ist er sechsmal zu Null geblieben, mit einer weißen Weste rausgekommen aus dem Spiel. Bei der U20-Weltmeisterschaft aus fünf Spielen auch immerhin zweimal. Da ist man dann bis ins Viertelfinale gekommen, wo man knapp gegen die Ukraine 0 zu 1 verloren hat. Wer erinnert sich nicht? Da kann man sich tatsächlich noch erinnern. Da sind es auch im Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen, Kolumbien. Das sieht ganz gut aus. Er kommt aus einer wunderbaren Stadt. Also einfach vom Namen her, Barankama, Barmecha. Das ist einfach schön. Na gut, ich gerate jetzt.
Narkos-Feeling?
Ja, schon so ein bisschen. Ohne die Drogen tatsächlich. Wen von der Südamerika, der Südamerika, Liste Amadeus, möchtest du noch vorstellen, gibt es da noch weitere? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir hier über ein paar Mehrspieler reden, als bei den bisherigen Kontinenten.
Also ich fand Gonzalo Plata noch relativ interessant, der jetzt ein schwieriges erstes Halbjahr hatte in Portugal, bei Sporting Lissabon, aber eben auch bei der U20-Werben für Ecuador, die, glaube ich, ins Halbfinale vorgerückt sind, einer der besten Spieler war. Und es galt eben auch als Coup von Sporting, dass man ihn eben verpflichten konnte, weil sogar Barcelona interessiert gewesen sein soll. Aber eben, wie gesagt, sein erstes Jahr in Portugal war bisher relativ bescheiden. Wenn er gespielt hat für Sporting, also er hat ein Spiel von Beginn gemacht, glaube ich, gegen Boa Vista, da hatte er relativ roh gewirkt, also, ich sag mal, bemüht, aber hatte noch sichtliche Schwierigkeiten, sich anzupassen an das schnellere Spiel, die Bälle sind ihm oft versprungen. Aber er hat eben ein Riesentalent, erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Uisebio, das sind so großen Schritten, toller Technik, und eben auch guter Torgefahr, gerade auch aus der Distanz, was ja bei so jungen Flügelspielern manchmal noch nicht ganz so ausgeprägt ist. Also, das könnte eine Name sein, denen es sich zu merken lohnt, aber ich glaube, jetzt die nächsten Wochen, Monate werden schon relativ entscheidend in seiner Karriere, aber eine Laie zu einem kleineren portugiesischen Verein könnte womöglich auch guttun. Also Gonzalo Plata, für mich ein sehr interessanter Spieler.
Spielt auf rechtsaußen, hat auch schon in der ekuadorianischen Nationalmannschaft, also in der Herren-Nationalmannschaft, in der Senioren-Nationalmannschaft, so ist es richtig, hat er gespielt und dann in der U20-Weltmeisterschaft, das hast du ja gerade schon angesprochen, da hat er alle Spiele gemacht und da ist man ja dann letztlich Dritter geworden nach einem Sieg im Spiel um Platz 3 Kolumbien. Sascha, gibt es noch jemanden, über den wir sprechen müssen?
Also am ehesten würde ich noch sagen, weil wir jetzt eigentlich noch gar keinen Argentiner angesprochen haben.
Das geht nicht an den Ruf der Andreas an.
Ja, eben, genau, sonst können wir uns morgen wieder was anhören. Erzunden Anruf von Andreas. Nein, also da würde ich vielleicht sogar tatsächlich sagen Thiago Almala von Vélez Sassfield. Argentinien, Zentraloffensive-Spieler, bringt auch unheimlich viel Flair mit, ist wendig, schnell am Ball, ist halt so ein typischer südamerikanischer Fußballer. Dieses Straßenfußballer gehen so in sich hat, aber trotzdem noch so diesen Zug zum Tor einfach nicht vermissen lässt. Also auch einfach ein wirklich, wirklich toller Spieler, der hoffentlich bald auch zur Alpi Celeste dazustoßen wird.
Ist ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, also kommt eben auch aus dem kreativen Bereich und wird hier schon mit einem irren Marktwert geführt. Soll man sich jetzt natürlich nicht komplett drauf anhängen. Das ist ähnlich wie Benotungen von Spielern, sind auch Marktwerte sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Aber wenn da 20 Millionen einfach mal steht, dann wundert man sich doch. Ja, dann zeigt das, okay, vielleicht ein Grund, warum man hier über ihn spricht. Und hat eben auch schon einige Spiele gemacht und in der Nationalmannschaft eben, du hast es gesagt, jetzt kann er vielleicht auch mal dann irgendwann bei den Senioren debütieren, aber vorher bei der U20 auch schon viele, viele Spiele gemacht. Und mit ja anscheinend ganz guten Leistungen, sonst wäre er bei euch nicht in der Liste gelandet. Ja, sehr gut. Bevor ich jetzt weiter alle Südamerikaner abfrage, ist ja auch albern, würde ich sagen. Das hört sich nach vielen interessanten Spielern an. Alle Namen findet man auf cavanisfrisör.de. Und dann werden wir einfach mal überprüfen. Vielleicht machen wir in 5 Jahren dann einfach das Was wurde aus. Und dann dürft ihr anfangen zu googeln, meine Herren. Dann wird es, glaube ich, interessanter, nämlich bei denjenigen, die einfach auf Tahiti geblieben sind. Und dann gucken wir mal, was da kommt. Oder gibt es noch einen Namen, der euch noch ganz wichtig ist? Ich habe ja jetzt so ein bisschen hier einfach freestylemäßig bin ich durch die Kontinente, über die Kontinente geflohen, an der Kaffeekanne-Style. Haben wir noch irgendjemand vergessen, Sascha, über den du sprechen willst? Ansonsten bist du ganz traurig und Amadeus kriegt gleich auch noch eine letzte Chance.
Ich überlege gerade noch ganz hektisch. Also Amadeus, da würde ich dir tatsächlich erst mit dir vortreten lassen.
Also ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass ich alle meine Bulletpoints abgearbeitet habe, aber...
Ich würde sagen, mit Almada haben wir eigentlich einen wirklichen Abschluss gefunden.
Sehr gut. Und das war ja sehr gut, deswegen reicht das auch definitiv. Dann danke ich euch beiden sehr für eure Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habe und für das Wissen, was ihr jetzt hiermit auch den Hörern und Hörern vermittelt habt. Zum einen Sascha Felter, et Sascha Fülter, also der Nachname, einfach ohne die Vokale auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Sascha. Also besser wird es heute nicht mehr. Ich danke auch sehr, sehr schönes Debüt hier im Rasenfunk. Amadeus Marzai, wenn wir dir ins Wort gefallen sind, lag es an der Latenz. Die war bei dir ein bisschen höher als bei Sascha. Also nimm es uns bitte nicht übel. Post ab, Amadeus, auf Twitter. Ja, schön, dass du da warst. Und dann danke ich euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 145. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen, der ja weiter werbesponsoren und paywall-frei ist. Auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützengibtes alle Infos dazu. Und auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de gibt es schönen Rasenfunk-Merch. In diesem Sinne danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Geht auf cavanisfrisur.de für alle Infos. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.